bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
faire le point sur Ant-Man 3 quantumania
on va pouvoir faire plein de belles
théories il y a beaucoup de choses à
dire mais voilà dans un premier temps
j'aimerais que l'on analyse ensemble ce
que l'on a sous les yeux et essayer de
voir ce que Marvel a voulu faire essayer
de comprendre par rapport au comics etc
et voilà par la suite on va pouvoir
balancer je le place d'ailleurs là mais
bien évidemment la vidéo va spoil
Ant-Man and the Wass quantumania donc
voilà vous êtes prévenus bon tout
d'abord il faut que nous parlions du MCU
de manière générale nous sortons enfin
de la phase 4 comme on en a beaucoup
parlé et Kevin fait Guy il a bien
rappelé c'était une phase de transition
il fallait conclure endgame terminé
certains récits relancer des super-héros
en introduire d'autres amener de
nouveaux concepts etc etc bref ils se
sont fait plaisir ils ont lancé plus les
séries tout le tralala mais maintenant
faut passer à la suite la phase 5 et la
fascisse on le sait de parler
déclarations et la révélation des films
c'est l'avènement de Kang le Conquérant
dans le MCU c'est un peu le nouveau
Thanos des trois prochaines phases et
bien évidemment il fallait l'introduire
et choix intéressant c'est que par le
biais d'antman 3 quantumania Marvel a
décidé d'amener la nouvelle phase et par
conséquent les lourds enjeux du futur de
la saga c'est intéressant car peu
importe le film qu'ils allaient nous
proposer le premier long-métrage de la
phase 5 avait pour vocation de
introduire quand le conquérant et le
mettre en lumière je dis ça car je sais
que certains ont eu du mal avec le film
et je peux le comprendre nous faisons
face à un film pour faire la promotion
de Kang le conquérant et sa dynastie
c'était comme ça quand même 3 était
vendu on a eu plein de trailers plein de
clips ou envoyer Kang plus que Scotland
lui-même limite et tout ça c'est pour
nous utiliser concernant la fin de la
fascisse avec Avengers the candynastie
et Secret Wars comme le film le dit
lui-même après tout Kang reviendra sauf
que de l'autre côté et bien on est dans
un film Ant-Man c'est à dire que l'on a
en face de nous un film faisant la
promotion de Kong de son introduction
ainsi que bah du futur de Marvel mais du
coup dans une enveloppe d'anthman donc
voilà je me doute que cela a pu en
perturber certains Marvel a fait un
choix plutôt intéressant mais
personnellement je vais pas mentir je
vais pas faire de chichi je suis plutôt
satisfait c'est vraiment exactement ce à
quoi je m'attendais pour un premier film
pour la phase 5 et introduisant un peu
l'avenir de Marvel et d'ailleurs le truc
c'est que les films Ant-Man ont toujours
eu une saveur un peu particulière c'est
de promouvoir un aspect externe qui
reviendra dans le futur de Marvel plus
précisément je parle du royaume quant et
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec endgame ou
grâce au film Ant-Man des concepts ont
été introduits puis utilisés dans le
film comme solution bref maintenant
parlons du film en lui-même et de ce
qu'il a introduit personnellement
j'attendais beaucoup Ant-Man quantumania
car voilà on en a beaucoup parlé en
vidéo mais on avait besoin d'avoir des
éclaircissements et plus précisément des
éclaircissements sur Kang et ce qu'il
prévoyait de faire en fait Kang est un
personnage extrêmement vaste des comics
qui est relié d'ailleurs à des concepts
bien spécifiques c'est un vilain hyper
iconique de l'univers Marvel et vu que
nous sommes dans le MCU et bien cela
veut dire adaptation réécriture bref le
personnage sera forcément modifié pour
coller à l'univers et au vu de son
immense histoire on avait besoin de voir
quel moment en gros Marvel on choisit
d'adapter pour le film et du coup bah du
MC dans ant Man 3 nous sommes face à un
Kang déjà bien établi et qui faisait
partie d'un rassemblement de variants de
lui-même mais c'était important de le
savoir car vous le savez Kong passe par
plusieurs
identités au cours de sa vie dans les
comics et la plupart du temps il est
seul à faire ses conquêtes à la base
Kang c'est juste un voyageur temporel
qui va se rendre compte que ces
manipulations du temps ont donné
naissance à d'autres lui-même qui
eux-mêmes donnent naissance à d'autres
là dans le MCU on est déjà à fond dans
l'ambiance multivers tout est déjà bien
installé et on avait besoin de le savoir
pour comprendre s'ils allaient
développer Kang petit à petit avec le
voyage dans le temps les identités la
prise de conscience des autres lui-même
etc etc ou si justement on allait
directement rentrer dans le conflit
multiversel pour gagner du temps
maintenant que nous avons enfin les
réponses on va pouvoir développer et je
vais vous exprimer clairement ma pensée
tout d'abord il faut la série Loki en
référence car je vous le rappelle mais
celui qui demeure et le variant qui a
gagné la guerre multiverselle et il nous
a expliqué toute l'histoire de comment
il en est arrivé là et d'ailleurs il
faut le rappeler mais nous sommes face à
une boucle la mort du personnage relance
la guerre multiverselle entre tous ces
variantes et comme annoncer de lui-même
c'est lui qui reviendra à la fin sont
lui du passé gagnera la guerre
multiverselle et deviendra le nouveau
celui qui demeure bref quand celui qui
demeure nous raconte son histoire il
nous explique qu'elle a toute base lui
et ses variant on fait la découverte que
les univers étaient empilés ce qui les a
conduits à se rencontrer une fois mise
en contact les variants ont mis en
commun leur savoir et leur technologie
s'auto améliorant entre eux ainsi que
l'univers des uns et des autres et c'est
exactement ce qui nous est montré dans
la scène post générique dantman les
variantes de Kang ont bâti un véritable
monument multivers où ils ont rejoint en
gros plusieurs de leurs flux temporelle
etc sauf que comme celui qui demeure
nous l'a expliqué pas tous les variants
étaient bienveillants pour certains les
autres univers symbolisés de nouveaux
mondes à conquérir et c'est exactement
le cas du variant dont nous avons fait
face dans ant Man 3 ce Kang est un
véritable conquérant qui a commis
d'innombrables atrocités et c'est
pourquoi il a été banni il voulait
conquérir et anéantir les autres univers
il était une véritable menace pour ses
compatriotes et ces derniers ont cherché
à le bloquer quelque part pour qu'il
n'agissent plus et c'est là que c'est
intéressant et que l'on va pouvoir
relier certains comics et émettre déjà
du coup certaines premières théories
nous faisons face dans la scène
post-générique au crosst time conceal of
Kangs avec un plan qui respecte
d'ailleurs à fond ce qui nous a été
proposé dans les comics néanmoins il y a
eu une réécriture de ce comité et je
dirais que nous faisons face à une
fusion effectivement dans les comics le
Conseil multiversel des Kangs est un peu
particulier en fait ce qu'il faut
retenir avant tout de ce comité pour le
MCU c'est la forme dans le sens où c'est
la Réunion totale des Kangs car dans le
fond dans les comics et bien ce ne sont
en fait tout ce que des
usurpateurs dans l'histoire le camp
principal que nous suivons après des
siècles de conquête à travers le temps à
assujetti énormément d'univers de
dimensions et autres mondes où il a
laissé des copies robotiques de lui-même
pour gouverner sauf que des entités ont
réussi à vaincre ses copies et grâce à
ça ils ont usurpé en gros l'identité de
Kang silence référent Man 3 et bien du
coup ce n'est pas le cas on est face à
un conseil multiversel des Kangs comme
dans les comics mais avec de véritables
variants et c'est là je pense que nous
pouvons parler de fusion je m'explique
en fait dans la scène post générique
d'entman nous faisons face à trois
variants qui semblent être à la tête de
ce comité multiversel des Kangs et ça
pour moi du coup bah c'est une belle
référence au comics quand le camp
principal va se rendre compte que ces
voyages temporels ont créé
d'innombrables variants de lui-même tous
plus dangereux les uns que les autres et
bien il va vouloir réagir et pour ce
faire il va créer un conseil des Kangs
qui n'est pas le Conseil multiversel des
Kangs c'est un autre conseil bref et ce
conseil en gros sera composé du coup bah
du Kang principal lui-même et de deux
autres variants et tous les trois ils
vont se donner pour mission d'éradiquer
la totalité de leur variant on retrouve
exactement ce même délire dans Ant-Man
avec le Conseil crosst time des Kangs
mais surtout il y a un détail très
important à relever en fait dans la
scène post générique d'anthman les trois
variants de Kang qui sont à la tête du
comité et bien ce ne sont pas du des
Kangs contrairement à tous les autres
dans le stade là il y a même des statues
de kank d'ailleurs qui sont au dessus
des gradins bref ça on aura bien
l'occasion de théoriser là-dessus j'ai
déjà pas mal de théories en tête et on
en parlera je pense dès la prochaine
vidéo mais voilà ce n'est pas un hasard
si pour moi dans le MCU ils ont choisi
que les trois têtes pensantes c'était
ramatoutes Immortus et bah du coup il
semblerait que ça soit Scarlet centurion
pour moi c'est le plus logique que ce
soit lui mais bref que ce soit ces
trois-là qui contrôlent en gros les
autres Kangs et qui dirigent l'Assemblée
en fait tout comme la vibe des comics ce
sont des variants qui à trois veulent
contrôler les autres variants préserver
ce qu'ils ont bâti et influencer
l'avenir et d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans les comics
Kang et tout le temps guidé et manipuler
sans qu'il le sachent par Immortus sa
dernière
identité la plus sage et maîtrisant le
temps c'est lui d'ailleurs qui a poussé
le Conquérant sans que ce dernier le
sache a créé le fameux conseil la
Détroit Kangs et traquer ses autres
variants ramatoutes la seconde forme la
plus âgée comme il semble nous être
proposé dans Ant-Man c'est un peu pareil
c'est une identité qui va aider et
accompagner Immortus à contrer les
actions de gang car c'est un Ramadan qui
a déjà normalement vécu sa période en
tant que Kang et il a envie de le
contrer etc et si je pense que le
dernier bah c'est Scarlet sont turion
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
bien évidemment mais voilà c'est parce
que ramatout dit à son confrère qu'il
doit regretter de ne pas avoir pu tuer
le Kang Bani de ses mains en plus il
semblerait que ce variant soit un peu
plus jeune que ces deux compères et
c'est quelque chose qui serait plutôt
cohérent dans l'adaptation des comics
dans le sens où je ne vais pas trop
m'étaler mais voilà Kang et Scarlet
centurion il y a une histoire les
entourants et Kang va trahir à un moment
donné Scarlet centurion bref ne nous
éparpillons pas trop pour le moment
concernant cette scène post générique il
y a vraiment beaucoup de choses à dire
sur ce sujet ça va être l'objet de pas
mal de vidéos je pense
parlons un peu du coup de l'autre scène
post générique intégrant Loki la série
Loki est hyper centrale pour le futur de
Marvel la saison 2 va sortir cet été et
perso je mise une pièce pour une
troisième saison qui sortira durant la
phase 6 en fait vu le nombre d'identité
que possède Kang la série Loki va nous
permettre de voir les backstage de tout
ce qui se passe concernant les variants
de Kang et ce peu importe les époques
car le TVA nous le permet c'est vraiment
en mode on a notre univers le 616 que
l'on suit au quotidien avec le
développement des héros de leurs
histoires etc et de l'autre côté on a
Loki qui va nous permettre de développer
tout l'univers de Kang et ses identités
jusqu'à ce que tout se rejoignent pour
la guerre multiverselle et la fin de la
saga du multivers le variant que l'on
voit dans la deuxième scène
post-générique intégrant Loki et Mobius
est Victor timely alors ne vous y
trompez pas c'est bel et bien un Kang le
Conquérant si le MCU a décidé de suivre
les comics mais au vu de la réaction de
mobbus en mode je le pensais plus
dangereux c'est bien pour nous tiser
quand même que le personnage nous cache
quelque chose dans l'histoire après une
défaite face aux Avengers dans le 20e
siècle un variant de Kang a décidé de
s'établir dans le Wisconsin et plus
précisément dans la ville de timely
durant l'année 1901 là-bas il a pris le
nom de Victor timely et a réussi à
devenir le maire de la ville il fondra
d'ailleurs l'entreprise timely
industries qui est une enseigne
spécialisée dans les principes de base
de la robotique la scène post-générique
semble suivre parfaitement cette
trajectoire et c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec la série Loki pour le
futur car des identités comme Victor
tamly il y en a plein et qui en plus ont
des histoires intéressantes je pense par
exemple à Mister griffon qui est un Kang
qui s'était établi dans le 21e siècle et
qui a fondé l'entreprise Keng en
rachetant la tour Stark Loki permettra
d'étoffer l'histoire et les identités de
Kang jusqu'à nous ramener celui qui est
censé devenir celui qui demeure et fact
intéressant mais le Conseil multiversel
des Kangs sera à terme détruit et vous
savez de quelle manière et bien par le
biais d'alayos contrôlé par le Kang
principal tout comme ce que nous a
raconté celui qui demeure celui qui
demeure est en soi le prime Kang c'est
comme ça que le Kang principal est
désigné dans les comics et du coup bah
c'est lui qu'il faut suivre avant tout
bon les petits mots quand même sur modo
ils ont vraiment fait une dinguerie avec
le personnage en vrai je ne suis même
pas déçu car je sais pas pourquoi mais
je le sentais gros comme une maison
sachant que Kang allait être l'entité
malveillante principale du film et qu'en
plus bah c'était Darren cross qui allait
devenir modoch suite à sa défaite dans
Ant-Man 1 bon ça sentait pas trop bon
pour le personnage en vrai en fait tu
sens le truc modoque c'est Darren c'est
juste pour que le personnage soit un
temps soit peu intéressant grâce à sa
liaison passée avec l'équipe de Scott et
puis bon ils n'ont pas respecté
l'essence du personnage oui modo que
c'est un acronyme pour dire organisme
mental conçu uniquement pour tuer mais
si modoch a une si grosse tête c'est
parce que c'est un humain devenu un
super ordinateur vivant
ultra intelligent et ce qui est
intéressant justement avec le personnage
c'est que il est devenu tellement
intelligent qu'il va se retourner du
coup contre les scientifiques qu'ils
l'ont créé et ils veulent les surpasser
bon on avait théorisé ensemble sur la
possibilité que Kang soit le créateur de
modoch dans le MCU et en soi c'était une
idée intéressante mais c'est vrai que du
coup bah de l'autre côté bah mode dog va
pas surpasser Kang qui est beaucoup plus
puissant et surtout cela entacherait un
peu ce nouveau grand méchant des futurs
phases sauf que du coup cela freine
moque au second plan au point qui il
n'est presque plus qu'un simple le
ragage mais voilà dans tous les cas ne
vous inquiétez pas on va bien rendre
hommage à ce protagoniste avec une belle
vidéo de pourquoi sont-ils si uniques ah
oui d'ailleurs petit truc que j'ai
oublié d'écrire dans mon script mais ça
m'a sauté aux yeux durant la scène
post-générique je sais pas pour vous
mais j'ai ressenti une énorme vibbe
Secret Wars Immortus là qui convoque
tous les Kangs sans leur demander dans
une sorte de grand stade etc j'ai pas
vous mais moi ça m'a fait complètement
penser au Beyonder qui convoque tous les
personnages de Marvel sur battle World
en vrai c'est un détail mais je trouve
que cela tise complètement ce qui nous
attend dans le futur
écoutez je pense que l'on va s'arrêter
là pour cette première vidéo alors je
vais continuer c'est tout trop sans
facecam parce que je n'ai plus de
batterie dans ma caméra c'est important
je trouve de faire un peu le point quand
un film vient de sortir n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à me poser des questions ou
soulever des points que j'aurais pu
potentiellement oublié en commentaire on
pourra y répondre dans une prochaine
vidéo j'espère quand même quant au Mania
vous aura plu le film a l'air quand même
de pas mal divisé je suis curieux de
voir vos avis en commentaire mais dans
tous les cas moi je sais pas je suis
satisfait par Kang et les scènes
post-génériques sincèrement ça promet de
fou et il y a plein de théories à faire
mais voilà faut tout d'abord digérer le
film dans un premier temps merci à tous
en tout cas d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que j'aurais été quand même
assez clair c'est quand même des sujets
un peu épineux l'histoire de Kang et ses
identités mais voilà n'hésitez pas à
voir de précédentes vidéos si vous
voulez en savoir plus car on développe
pas mal l'histoire des comics je pense
notamment à pourquoi Kang le conquérant
et si unique et puis n'oubliez pas de
laisser un petit pouce bleu qui me
soutient énormément n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner on a plein de vidéos à faire que
le linehouse soit avec vous les amis cet
état goroch allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]